>> ♪ ♪
>> Sean: A LOT OF BREAKING NEWS
WITH THE DEEP STATE INCLUDING
EXPLOSIVE DEVELOPMENTS IN THE
CASE OF MICHAEL FLYNN AND MAJOR
QUESTIONS LOOMING LARGE.
WHEN WE WILL GET THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S REPORT.
THIS IS PREMEDITATED FRAUD ON
THE COURT?
JOINING US FOR REACTION CHAIRMAN
OF THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, SENATOR LINDSEY
GRAHAM.
WE KNOW THAT 4 SEPARATE TIMES
THE FBI AND DOJ WERE WARNED NOT
TO USE THE DIRTY DOSSIER.
YOU AND SENATOR GRASSLEY HAD A
MEMO THAT SAID THE BULK OF THE
APPLICATION WAS THE RUSSIAN
DOSSIER HILLARY CLINTON PAID
FOR.
WAS THAT FRAUD ON THE COURT AND
THOSE WARRANTS WERE ILLEGALLY
OBTAINED?
I AM NOT THE AG, BUT TO ME IT
SEEMS LIKE A SLAM DUNK, EASY
CASE, BOOM.
>> WE WILL SEE WHAT MORE
HOROWITZ SAYS.
I CAN PROMISE YOU THIS, THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WILL
CALL MR. HOROWITZ AND HE WILL
TESTIFY UNDER OATH ABOUT HIS
REPORT.
WE WILL PURSUE THIS IN A
TRANSPARENT FASHION AND
DECLASSIFY AS MUCH AS WE CAN
INCLUDING THE FISA WARRANTS AND
GIVE YOU ALL OF THE INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW SUSPICIOUS PEOPLE WERE
OF CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND HOW
BIASSED HE WAS.
LET YOU READ IT FOR YOURSELF.
ACCOUNTABILITY IS MY GOAL.
>> Sean: WELL, YOU KIND OF
DUCKED MY QUESTION.
WANT TR
WANT --
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE WILL
SAY.
>> Sean: YOU ARE A LAWYER AND
SMART AND A SENATOR.
YOU HAVE FOLLOWED THIS CASE AS
CLOSELY AS I HAVE.
DO YOU BELIEVE IT IS
OVERWHELMING, THAT THE EVIDENCE
SHOWS ONE THING.
PREMEDITATIVE FRAUD ON THE FISA
COURT AND WARRANTS OBTAINING
ILLEGALLY DENYING THE PRESIDENT
HIS CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AND
ALLOWING SPYING ON HIM?
>> HERE'S WHAT I BELIEVE WITHOUT
ANY DOUBT.
THE DOSSIER IS UNVERIFYED TO
THIS DAY.
IT'S A BUNCH OF GARBAGE.
THAT THE AUTHOR OF THE DOSSIER
WAS ON THE PAYROLL OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
HE WAS UNRELIABLE AND THE SYSTEM
HAD NOTICE ABOUT HIS BIAS.
THEY OBTAINED A WARRANT ON 4
DIFFERENT OCCASIONS AND WILL BE
HELD TO ACCOUNT FOR THAT.
MR. DURHAM WILL DECIDE WHO TO
PROSECUTOR.
MY GOAL IS TO EXPLAIN HOW THE
SYSTEM FAILED AND MAKE SURE IT
NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
I WILL MAKE SURE THAT ROSENSTEIN
AND McCABE ARE CALLED BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TO EXPLAIN WHAT
HAPPENED REGARDING CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT WIRETAPPING PRESIDENT
TRUMP AFTER THE ELECTION.
TO ME THAT'S A CHILLY MOMENT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE ACTING
ATTORNEY GENERAL, THE ACTING FBI
CHIEF, ABOUT WIRETAPPING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> Sean: THAT WAS BEYOND
SHOCKING TO ME.
THANK GOODNESS FOR JUDICIAL
WATCH.
>> AMEN.
>> Sean: THEY ARE DOING A GREAT
JOB.
I CAN'T MENTION EVERYBODY.
SOMEONE WOULD GET MAD AT ME.
I APPRECIATE THE FACT YOU WILL
ASK WHETHER THERE WAS A RIGGED
INVESTIGATION INTO HILLARY
CLINTON'S EMAILS.
YOU WILL FIND OUT IF THE
COUNTER-INTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION STARTED IN THE
WHITE HOUSE OF BARACK OBAMA.
WHAT DID HE KNOW?
YOU WILL FIND THAT OUT TOO?
>> YES, I WANT TO FIND OUT WHAT
THE CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION
WAS IT RIGGED IN HER FAVOR
BECAUSE OF POLITICAL BIAS?
WAS THE COUNTER-INTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION BASED ON THE
DESIRE TO GET INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN WHEN THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE OF RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE?
WAS THE FISA WARRANT BASED ON
FRAUD?
WAS THE CERTIFICATION OF THE
COURT PERJURY?
DID THEY SURVEIL THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN IMPROPERL
CAMPAIGN IMPROPER L
CAMPAIGN IMPROPERLY?
IF THERE WAS NO REASON TO
BELIEVE THAT MICHAEL FLYNN WAS A
RUSSIAN AGENT WHY DID THE HELL
DID THEY TALK TO HIM ANYWAY?
>> Sean: AND THE THEY TOLD FLYNN
HE DIDN'T NEED A LAWYER WHEN HE
DID NEED A LAWYER.
AND COMEY SAID YEAH, I TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF THE CHAOS AND PUT
ALL PROCEDURE ASIDE.
I WOULD DO NOT THAT IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
BUT YES, I DID THAT.
I SCREWED A 33-YEAR MILITARY
VET.
>> WE WERE TALKING ABOUT 9-11.
I SERVED WITH GENERAL FLYNN IN
AFGHANISTAN WHEN HE WAS A
RESERVIST.
HE IS A PATRIOT.
THE QUESTION FOR ME:
IF ALL OF THE THINGS YOU SAID
ARE TRUE, WHO SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE?
DID THEY TRICK GENERAL FLYNN?
DID THEY HAVE A BELIEF HE WAS
WORKING WITH THE RUSSIANS?
WHY WOULD THE EXISTING
ADMINISTRATION SURVEIL THE IN
COMING ADMINISTRATION?
>> Sean: BINGO.
DID THEY SUB-CONTRACT SPYING TO
OUR WESTERN INTELLIGENCE
FRIENDS?
I AM JUST GUESSING:
GREAT BRITAIN, ITALY, AUSTRALIA,
CANADA?
>> RIGHT.
LET ME JUST FILL IN THE BLANKS
HERE.
DID THE PERSON WHO INFORMED
PAPADOPOULOS THAT THE CLINTON
EMAILS WERE HACKED, WAS THERE
ANY EVIDENCE AT ALL THAT
PAPADOPOULOS WAS WORKING WITH
THE RUSSIAN?
I HAVE NOT SEEN ONE PIECE OF
EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST HE WAS
WORKING WITH THE RUSSIANS.
>> Sean: I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
EVIDENCE IN THAT CASE.
BUT I AM SO STUPID.
THANK YOU, SENATOR.